what's up guys so in part 1 of this
video I discussed how invidious new
ampere and tearing product lines were
going to save the prices of graphics
cards at the time ampere was supposed to
be a gamer of series and Turing was
supposed to be a mining series while the
mining series obviously wouldn't have
the same resale value as a gaming
graphics card if it was good enough and
at a good price then it definitely would
have sold well and taken at least a
little demand off of the gaming card
market thus leading to a drop in prices
these cards were supposed to be revealed
at GGC and released in April recently
however an article on Tom's Hardware
claimed that both series weren't going
to come til the second half of this year
and also suggested that Turing would be
a gaming series and ampere it was
actually gonna be the next generation of
Walton that actually makes more sense
because in media probably doesn't care
who is buying their cards and there's no
need for them to give away more
performance but I'm so hoping that those
first rumours come out to be true but
either way there has been some more news
that has surfaced right now that
graphics cards will drop in price
despite whether or not these new
graphics cards come out soon so what
happened well as you guys may already
know the difficulty to mine various
crypto currencies like aetherium has
constantly been rise also most of the
people who had wanted to mine have
sufficient mining rigs or they aren't
sure if they should expand delivery
setups right now
long story short cryptocurrency prices
have been dropping and it is also
getting harder to mine things like a
theorem and this is ultimately leading
to less demand from miners for graphics
cards the reason that graphics cards are
so overpriced right now is because of
the crazy demand put on by miners in
particular so as a result if miners are
taken out of the picture then there
would be significantly less demand for
the graphics cards and thus their prices
would definitely drop and that's how
it's super-simple and it really is but
how long will it take for prices to
stabilize and well graphics cards return
to MSRP
well here's bad news
it's still going to take a while for
graphics cards to return to MSRP GPU
price hole probably stabilized in the
second half of 2018 but they still won't
return to MSRP until the fourth quarter
of this year or even started 2019 if
minors are out then why would still take
that long well here's the thing gamers
have been waiting for a very long time
to be able to build a PC and many of
them have stalled these are the extreme
price of GPUs as it is evident most
gamers are very unwilling to pay double
the price for a GPU but many gamers are
probably willing to spend 150 to 250
dollars over MSRP in order to avoid
waiting even longer I think we're going
to see some something similar to the
8700 K or the people who are willing to
spend $50 over MSRP were able to get
their CPUs instantly while the rest of
people had to wait a couple of months
for prices to return to MSRP
so using that past experience and
assuming that miners are truly out of
the picture graphics card prices will
start to drop in the end of March story
at the beginning of April as the demand
from gamers also slowly fades away after
about three to four months which was
about how long it took for 8700 K prices
to stabilize graphics cards will
stabilize in price so overall GPU should
stabilize to the much more reasonable
price in july or august but why is it
still a reasonable price why isn't it
just MSRP there isn't above normal
demand for the graphics cards right well
that may be true but you have to
remember that Ram prices will still play
a role in GPU prices and obviously we
have RAM shortage right now which will
turn in turn also affect GPU prices but
fortunately that effect will be much
less than what miners had on the
graphics cards at this point GPUs will
only be fifty two hundred dollars over
MSRP instead of double or two hundred
dollars above
fortunately Ram prices are expected to
return to MSRP at third or fourth
quarter of this year so as a result we
should be able to expect GPUs being
offered for MSRP and a holiday season of
this year or the beginning of 2019
Plus by then the next series of graphics
cars will be out and those will further
lower the prices of 10 series GPUs so
you guys will have a lot of option this
holiday season you should be able to
pick up a next year's GPU for Holi
season and a nice discount or tens your
GPU for a good bargain which I put very
great options really but that's pretty
much it for why graphics cards prices
are going to be going down soon
hopefully so what do you guys think do
you think mine is actually done or do
you think you'll return after in the
future after this little downfall we're
experiencing right now make sure to post
review guys are thinking
I read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts but that's all I
have for you guys this time if you guys
like this video then make sure to drop a
like and subscribe if you want to see
more videos just like this but until
next time bye
[Music]